thank you
[Music]
so you guys uh ever go to Chick-fil-A
yes and how long does it take usually
for you to feel feel the homophobia in
there uh well like you said how long
does it take and I said to feel the
homophobia inside yeah that's exactly
what this is about if you're going uh
and it's peak hour and it's pretty
trafficky 20 minutes
really fast what you it takes you 20
minutes that's not the highest like wow
Sunset where the line is into the street
oh yeah yeah yeah 20 minutes I've never
been there longer than that always got a
line though dude what about in and out
how long that's even longer though that
line is [__] long only in the
drive-through yeah the line on the
inside always moves fast even if you
have to wait for the food I've waited
for 30 minutes in line before I've
waited for 45 years drive through is
pretty crazy for that yeah but the in
and out sometimes is so bad that it goes
into the Main Street yeah yeah I'll do
it all the time during covet one time
when we're somehow allowed to go to In
and Out I remember me and Nina waited in
line for like an hour and 10 minutes
practically gets to the 101. but then
when you see it you don't just go let's
just skip it because you can see how
long it's going to be yeah you go oh
it's just I'm just really craving it
when she wants something you gotta give
it to her you don't tell her a lie come
on it's closed down
you don't guys you don't wait in line
like you don't do you guys you guys wait
in line like that's the thing you do
we'll go inside and stand there if I
really want it what do you do you cut
the line
nah people try to cut the line I drive
away I usually just come back later like
you know like my the place I really like
the katsu spot in Vegas oh yeah so I'll
go there and then it was like oh [__]
hour I was about to come back another
time and I'll ask them when they open
and they're like five so the next time I
come I go at like 4 40. just so I could
get in there because I don't want to
waste time now imagine you have a
monocomb of power a little bit of power
you have some authority over s.a.t
Awards you got some juice man a little
bit here Obama yeah no no you got like
like power over your local Mini
municipality right and you're all
Mitchell your food inspector yeah or
you're no you're you can you're like a
city comptroller like you can like
control you get so [__] controllers
so funny so I don't know what that means
yeah you get so angry waiting in line at
this Chick-fil-A for so many hours for
so many days that you have this place
ordered for Demolition
and Chick-fil-A has is forced to rebuild
a new drive-through location
what that's closer to his office no no
no no they can't [__] Chick-fil-A
can't sue him for demolizing is their
place demolition
so in one in one in one North Carolina
city the Chick-fil-A lines that spill
into city streets got so insane that
City officials are making them demolish
the whole [__] thing and start over
why is it they're like I don't like the
way that it's designed right it's
messing up with the infrastructure I
think it's because of what I said
um they're saying it's like the spilling
into the [__] traffic [__] I think
it's because a guy got pissed and he's
like [__] this [__] I'm gonna demo all
of it do it again and do it better
that's not their fault that their
stuff's so tasty yeah I know is it a
crime to have a busy business
no but if it [__] with the local
traffic then apparently it is city
planners say the restaurant's new design
will prevent cars from backing up onto
the main road which was a primary issue
and the two the two drive-through Lanes
wrap around the restaurant
um so it's like two lanes going all the
way around that might be a good idea
though yeah I mean yeah you know it's
going to be a little bit of work and a
lot of bit of money for a short period
of time and then suddenly it's gonna be
like 20 years of Chick-fil-A there you
know what I'm saying or just open on
Sundays relief the Saturday traffic
because Saturday just gets so insane
because people are following so hard
yeah man
yeah what are people gonna do on Sunday
when they're hungry and they want
Chick-fil-A Raising Canes I always want
Chick-fil-A on Sunday though I don't
know isn't that a weird thing it hits
you and you're like oh dude you go weird
well that's like McDonald's breakfast I
always want it when it's too late and
I'm like
145 or something you know that's
something I always wanted to do with
Chick-fil-A fries I always wanted to
order large waffle fries and cut them up
and see what the equivalent amount
actually is oh because it takes up so
much yeah I always wanted to take the
the fries the waffle fries and put them
together and make a potato
I always wanted to ask them how come you
can't come out with criss-cut fries like
Carl's Jr
do you like theirs better yeah what's
the difference what's the difference
this season I think that's the seasoning
is better dude Jack in the Box
dude actually Jack in the Box does have
really good Seasons they're curly fries
for different reasons I just love their
tastes that's because I do like a
Chick-fil-A
um a fry especially when it's perfectly
salted and you get a little bit of the
the potato skin on it and it's just like
have you guys sauce dip come on have you
had the egg rolls at Jack In The Box no
all their non-burgers this is so good
dude they used to have a really you
might even taste Filipino huh
don't make me mad better potato wedges
at Jack In The Box yeah all their not
Burger Food their tacos are good I get
the tacos they used to have a good
chicken teriyaki bowl dude they used to
yeah they did they used to have a good
uh oh it was good too it was pretty sad
a good beef udon too yeah
is that Burger King dude you can yeah
you can get a live lobster is that
French toast sticks
have you ever had the chicken fajita
pita I have at the Jack In The Box
no that's a little food hack there if
you want to save on the carbs chicken
fajita you just eat the chicken outside
of it and throw away the pizza is that
where you get shoveling about to yeah
yeah they got dim sum there yeah and
kebabs I don't know man that's that's
kind of [__] up
I think it's I think it's really [__]
up and it's only because I understand
what it's like to build a business as a
business owner what if this was this was
you you'd have to be too busy you have
to move it there's a lot of things that
I realized where um City people have so
much [__] power and they can really
make you have a bad day if they just
feel like yeah and it's it should be
hella legal because it's basically
corrupt right yeah they could just be
like you know what I kind of don't like
you that much so um I'm just gonna take
my time
and I'm not gonna prove you imagine
certain things imagine this is the first
Chick-fil-A like they're probably done
yeah yeah like for example oh how sad
yeah I just have to think of it that way
right like right now
um what's happening in Honolulu is the
building committee and a lot of City
officials they got in trouble by the FBI
there was a huge investigation they were
taking bribes like outright envelopes of
money all this [__] right so basically
like half the city workers just got done
like they're they're like fired so they
have to rush to hire all these new
people and now all these new people
they're new they don't know how to
[__] do this stuff they're also like
understaffed and then they're backed up
with all of these uh permitting things
right so before you open up and build
your business or let's say like during
covid someone wanted to remodel their
kitchen or whatever all those things
have to go through the permitting
process so the City Architects can just
be like all right that's cool that's
cool that's safe right yeah
now a lot of these small businesses like
after a year of just not being able to
reopen their business paying rent they
all just died
because the city workers were just
[__] being corrupt and then the new
guys have to cover what the you know bad
guys [__] up and they're just like
dude how the [__] are they ever gonna
catch up and they're still backed up and
there's nothing new to just be like all
right because we [__] up as a city and
we're not doing our jobs small
businesses all you guys that are getting
hurt by us like I don't care maybe just
open or so it's forcing people to be
illegal because now people have to be
like well [__] I don't know um I know
it's against the law to just build and
maybe I might have to rebuild this
kitchen if I did it wrong but I'm just
gonna do it because then if I don't then
how am I gonna yeah yeah I'm gonna feed
my family exactly a lot of people just
were forced to be illegal because of the
incompetence of you know the city and
how they mismanage [__] and I'm like
this is the stuff that they don't really
talk about a lot because the people
that's hurting is just business owners
and business owners get this bad rep of
like you know bad capitalist greedy guys
but most of the people that it's [__]
up are small families and small family
business owners not the corporate Giants
that can afford it like they did this to
McDonald's they could close for two
years whatever they'll just reopen right
but like
the small diners and like all them
they're getting [__] and they don't
come back that's like all the mom and
pop shops on Garvey Avenue because Kobe
[__] them up and then now there's so
many stores that are just like boarded
up and it looks so sad yeah it does look
super sad yeah that's why Chick-fil-A is
gonna be fine dude you can open a
Chick-fil-A for 10 G's dude they make so
much money I heard you have to work
there for like 10 or 15 years yeah you
gotta like put in work and [__] yeah and
and the low-key you gotta be Christian
that's a hierarchy what's interesting
too I've never seen a 7-Eleven have to
leave or close dude and the one in um
off Washington in the Fashion District
left whoa because for the reason that
too many homeless people were there's
one by my house yeah there's one about
my house that that happened to and it
was like it was right next to the
Community College
so like people go there all the time but
one of my old clients used to work over
there and he said
the only after a certain period of time
the only people that go in there were
just homeless people and they had to
just close down you could always tell
which Starbucks has to deal with like a
homeless problem and they're the ones
where you need a code to use the
bathroom oh yeah well then close you
just go in and just pee whatever but
then the ones that like they yeah they
get some rushed to everyone in L.A
though they closed like three of them in
Hollywood for that reason yeah because I
was just in San Diego in the same thing
I've never seen anything like it too I
grew up there and there's like [__]
everywhere every single 7-Eleven was
like like camped around yeah and you
have all these like little Baristas that
are scared because they're like people
come in talking themselves
[__] like what do I do yeah owns a fried
chicken restaurant in in the hood like
it's so it's like a bank when you walk
in Louisiana straight up that's my spot
bar like the windows are all [__]
like you know and they give you a food
in a little slot like that and they used
to have public restrooms because she's
like yeah people need to go to the
bathroom right and she goes the last
draw was like for like a week straight
there'll be a different crackhead just
smoking up in the bathroom for hours
while like families are knocking on the
door trying to use the bathroom yeah
and then so she's got no more bathrooms
dude yeah my crackers need so much
privacy yeah yes smoke it at the park
like every other crack yeah I don't get
it they still do that too I never got
that about crackheads never did
all right
foreign